something wrong Emperor are we
negotiating our agreement winged bird
who there's that row cool
so um yes I'm Erin black um um obviously
he's kind of patterned after like a
classic you know kind of Wild West you
know Varsha wood gunslinger bounty
hunter his primary weapon set are the
two revolvers he has on his weight so he
utilizes those a lot in his fight style
she's a lot of streams that uses them to
pistol-whip people or what my favorite
ones right there where like he kicks to
hammer and fires a shot and some kind of
neat about him is a lot of his fights on
attacks that utilize the revolvers I'm
actually have much more range than a
normal liver punch would have so I think
maybe was going to uh some of this
specials and standard special Center um
so beside the revolver is one things he
has access to is I always been kind of
wandering the out world you know for all
these years you know you know killed
some you know crazy monsters and take us
in with their magic it's one of the
things he has is a like a sand filled
like glass globes were made he can roll
across the floor
kind of a slow moving low projectile
those are always pretty good anything
it's the you know projectile full screen
load right um you can actually enhance
that one to control its speed and it'll
also fire off a shot and break it and
that will need to pop up so that can be
used as comm extenders or good overs you
can roll behind the guy roll out in
front of them the press set up up you
know roll for the guys trying to get out
like that um in addition he can break
the Globes
over his head for like a like a good
anti-air I was kind of fast and go to a
whole lot of damage but it's really good
for us top of jump ins thread you can
also use the star combos of the team
combos keep warm either there we go so
he also has a pretty powerful low
special the slide has a pretty good
range on it does a decent damage in that
one also he can enhance
and he will write them off a couple of
shots with revolvers and that's great
for complementor is also rare you know
creating some some awesome close up
situations in addition to that so what
else he has he has like a medium range
tackle it's a pretty good-looking
command grab tackle you know rifle also
shots in the mace and it also can be
meter burns and it will do a bit more
damage and separate the characters quite
a bit more that's an example this is
this throw again resin so the revolvers
a lot of the logical situations
happiness beginning I'm not getting it
today well it's alright ring jitters
okay all right now Tyler again ah
I'm not quitting to get this do it hey
you're that [ __ ] combos crate some
distance you know put people into
corners away from corners things like
that and then probably my favorite
specially because he has these caltrops
which if everyone knows my caltrop is
not a spiked nail
he throws a handful of mud on the ground
if he can do that at different ranges
you know close medium or far and when
you're standing at home it does some
damage over time but the cool thing
about it is it will also force your
opponent to stop running so if they're
running at you it actually stops their
run so you can kind of set it up as a
little trap to keep the player for being
a too offensive these are also good to
throw down when you knock someone down
or we get someone trapped in a corner to
for some tread jump out you can create
some combo opportunity and I believe
that soon yes common is a common is
common set
so in marksman he has this rifle like a
long rifle on his back and he gains
access to a few new special moves with
it
so maybe be like his walk back so pretty
unique special where he actually walks
and creates range at the same time he's
um he's firing off three very quick
projectiles kind of an office favorite
because it creates distance and
it's going to feel like a defensive kind
of style but also often at the same time
and you can enhance that version and
he'll actually switch up the shots up a
little bit too high visit this good
couple opportunities if you can get in
fast enough you know to close that gap
that you created from the walk back so
it's actually really powerful the corner
because you won't be spread so far away
that you'll be able to come again right
um additionally he has like a sniper
shot where you can kind of charge up a
turn to a blast on the ground so you can
hold that and you hold that whole now
I'm just going to hold that and - cancel
out of it and now look things at Paul
Weiss to do with this you can actually
two and one into it and then - cancel it
like in the middle of streams and stuff
to create like some seasons you have to
be willing to set opportunities and then
he also has a pop-up pumper cuts with
the rifle so this is good again for you
know combo injures things like that you
can sneak in some some general hits
after that one but that you enhance it
then he actually fires a shot afterwards
now that when you can get in you're like
oh you know you
yeah and I think you've got all your
meter so it may be a good time - um I -
off maybe as x-ray oh I'm like oh I can
fake it oh there it is I want to do that
but tricks
that is a magic bullet right there he
comes for period matches he writes the
opponent's name to the Braille uses a
sharpie beforehand just in case yeah
whoever came up that is a genius who was
that Derek I think we shoot wasn't it
don't kid me she was yeah what it was
that's cool so the other have unique
thing about his his x-rays it leaves the
opponent standing at the end so can be
used for all kind of you know crazy
mix-up on my right yeah that's pretty
much marksman okay awesome maybe go to
go to another one
sounds good keep the bear black train
rolling again choo-choo hair black let's
do it outlaw no weird yeah
so Ella what to to reflect she went look
Harun black on Aaron black oh my lovey
how are we prepared for this I don't
know I don't know which one did you do
do good idea I do that loss you should
gunslinger okay absolutely we probably
should a be quiet for the intro we
haven't gotten there yet but alright I'm
just I'm just praying yeah I'm just
prepping okay alright
we prepped for a long time yeah we did
yeah those add too much mind games don't
work on me there's an obvious insult
there you'd best shut up and draw yeah
what so cool um all right let's go
through I guess outlaw so Allah has
primary weapon in the game he has to
have broken off Charcot Warriors are um
had his lots of sword weight attached to
it something that's pretty pretty unique
conceptual weapon and of course this
variation kind of revolves around that
so he gains access to some high style
attacks with it so I get some new
screams accomplished rings rate you know
uses a toad that's gonna bring a damage
good range eyes to bina has one were
just a little little commander IV kind
of attack after it and he also was
throwing sands and combos as well too
yeah yeah some of the spiced I'll study
actually that you know fix a handful
stand up up and Brennan rosin the
opponent's face a little bit of a side
um but I guess other example apologist
trick the game so probably his biggest
asset in this variation is his staff but
the impale that out there we go and so
this will actually break the blade off
in the opponent's chest and that will
add a damage over time lead component
and while that's active he doesn't have
access to any of those sort of tax and
of course if you do the you know an
enhanced version of it it'll bleed will
last longer to do more damage but it'll
be more time where your sword is gone
and since you can't you have access on
the district it's your text and I
believe this we also gets a modified
version of the sand burst where actually
picks up the you Tampa will say off the
Greco's in the face it actually creates
stun situation like a true stun which
would be 2 and 1 into if I can do things
like set up obviously set of combos or
set up a free upheld
right
there were our exams no Slayer lovers
kill them
Oh you also notice the different of
Pelton's to that there's the green and
black along the preposition he's fine
today oh he's fine he's told I'll be
back sometimes around you know we're
gonna be fine
your rematch here now we'll go through
the final air and guts winger yeah Oh
Jeff
we actually don't man all this
variations are really good it might be
my favorite
no no that's what you said about the
last one I don't know it's just the wet
paper wet day okay all right John who
doesn't escape somebody with a broken
off forearm I mean uh I've always wanted
but you may or may not be Brock I don't
know oh I don't know maybe the isolation
who knows who knows
so gunslinger revolves more around his
revolvers noble acts of a pun that's
good oh so the big thing for this one is
a has a standoff stance soon because
this will stand off kind of like you
know Wild West you know guns tinder
standoff stance and from that he has
access to some additional specials so he
has like a low kind of like disco dance
and he's warming more and got a book
through are the more hits it does and
you know it's a low so that's always
good you don't mess up he has this anti
hair it's like super fast like
quick-draw with both revolvers prepares
jump and really well and I've used into
juggles and and he also has it like a
retreating shot where he fires a
two-shot style off the back we know
those of that yeah there we go and now
it's goodness again it can kind of look
like a modified version of the the rifle
where you can't get a trace of distance
but fire all night really fast reject
owls um and then I also has my favorite
special coin toss means a really cool
little show after after this fire
bullets everywhere
coin tosses is 'kathy flip the coin up
in the air and you get a ricochet
gunshot off of it and you can actually
change the trajectory of that vision
which direction you holes and improv is
an enhanced version it does a whole
handful off it just you know fires off a
bunch of shots money yeah that can be
done you know in combos and be done to
you know kind of be open ball range
mid-range pokes be combo into in some
situations from you know mid screens off
of white side our way to just really
cool stuff now if you over drawers with
bank accounts over points as you have he
apparently has an unlimited supply boom
13 yeah it would be a bounty hunter it
tastes it pays well so you know it just
gets all this baby chickens or whatever
and so that is that is oh that's so
that's that's hair black and eventually
I'm sure we'll be showing you know more
gameplay stuff we don't have like many
more gameplay stuff from you know as
long as the game is closer to to release
but that is mr. Aaron black boom very
exciting take that for me hi certainly
you